oh we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
psycheck your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and we're here with look I did
it the right way look look however
clever I am I'm fighting the right way
uh how it's only been two years uh
tariff and stormy bear how are you
gentlemen
awesome we'll throw in the intro and
then we'll get into the conversation
thank you
[Music]
right so we're gonna have a little
conversation about the Stargate and the
uses of the Stargate so obviously it's a
transportation turn it off
[Music]
immediately aren't you
say enough soon enough soon enough
it's obviously a transportation device
that you can use to instantly travel
between worlds of course what else
is the Stargate
um before we get into that
we always talk about what have we
watched this week what are we watching
what about you guys what you're watching
this week or you've been watching
anything or have you just been too damn
busy
you've watched Mrs impossible I've
watched a couple of things go on them
yeah uh oh guys so Mission Impossible
seven I I really enjoyed it I thought it
was excellent
um makes me really excited for the next
part of course I still think it stands
alone very well but I did enjoy it a lot
um I finished beef which was great
I love beef
uh
I feel like I watched something else uh
I can't think of it though those are the
two big Heavy Hitters for me I guess
this week oh well I guess I I watched
the penultimate episode of Mayans the
first two episodes of what we do in the
shadows because there are new seasons
there which is great and I'm sad
apparently my we don't get that over
here we don't really get that over here
I'm sure I could watch if I wanted to
but nobody does what we do in the
shadows yeah but it's an old like
American show from unions to go isn't it
so that didn't really you know it's only
like it's new this is really it's uh
fourth year based on an old show
revive sort of thing no 2015 movie
uh-huh it's in the same universe as it
and they have a couple of New Zealand
shows that are smaller shows that kind
of correlate with it too so there's like
monster shows for New Zealand which are
pretty damn funny uh but this is just
just a little little small thing I enjoy
it a lot it's one of the the best
comedies out right now and
thank thank you for it because we need
more comedy so I'm happy that it's there
the store man whichever Walking Dead if
you watch this week yeah yes
zero Walking Dead
I started for
what I started
re-binging uh Stargate so I started that
I think last week and I'm up to season
three uh Daniel just found out about the
heresis child and that's that's where
I'm up up to this morning uh the other
thing I've been watching is I watched
the ever loving shed out of the season
two episode one of foundation
I was going to ask with the news
I will say Lee Pace I think enjoys that
his ass clothes on
just saying he's just likes to act
yeah
it's warm it's a bit hot it's a bit hot
right yeah right right he's from the UK
he's in the desert he you know he's got
to take some stuff off so that was that
was it was an excellent excellent yeah I
just watched the last episode ready for
the new series
um which is this week
I watched the last episode just to
refresh my memory
because it's quite a complicated little
fella Foundation
you have to have your wits about you
hear yourself is a little bit mad you
can't watch that while playing on your
phone like what happened what what
happened something just happened
um I I finished watching Silo finally as
well and oh man I can't wait for second
season of that which will be God knows
when thanks to the stroke but um
uh yeah it was it was quite excellent so
I really enjoyed that little twisted
that was a Twist and Turn you know that
Harris you would love it
away and then they just and then they
turn up the heat and they throw you
around and then they Sizzle away again
but anyway let's get into the episode
so we're going to be talking about the
Stargate and how it can be used to
something other than just a
transportation device so first on my
list
is using the Stargate as a weapon
guys what well what did we for one what
did we see when did we see it used as a
weapon in the show
half the time no well as a delivery
device you know certainly you know you
know um dial the gate and throw in a
nuke I mean we that's been wrong if I'm
calling Luke nuke stud
but yeah so yeah with as a living I mean
just as a weapon of like putting troops
through
yeah okay that's using it as a weapon
and transporting thing so
um
yeah the Asgard used as a weapon Brett
when do they ask God use it as a weapon
I don't remember that
um
so remind me remind us of that sir I
can't remember so um
we we prevented it being used as a
weapon of bear bit by having the the
iris do we
yes very awesome
use the uh gate against the replicators
was that it
they trans they used it and they they
put their weapon through it didn't they
the anti-azgard weapon uh sorry the
anti-replicator weapon but then they
used the gate to
extend it out around the Galaxy didn't
they so yes it is yeah I think I think
it's
okay yeah I think that's maybe what he's
talking about so that's yes spot on
um but like I said used it as a um like
as a as a antenna didn't they kind of
thank you antenna energy storage device
oh yeah both
yeah we can use it as a storage device I
think yeah I think using it as a battery
is actually a pretty good idea because
it can actually hold a massive charge oh
yes it can and it creates energy itself
to a degree so or at least the the
dialing device tends to so
huh
um you've got the obviously somebody
mentioned a second ago chilling in the
basement hello sir
um Sam did blow up a star so that's the
elephant in the room
she could have you know come up with a
non-collateral damage plan but she
didn't she decided to destroy everything
um hooking up to a black hole suck a
load of mass at the star sudden collab
boom
um
is there any other ways that can be used
as a weapon
I mean you can supercharge it itself and
and kind of I mean you could pull a
dakara purposefully if you wanted to uh
I mean there's a lot of things you do
you could Trojan Horse it in a sense
where you could send somebody a Stargate
and then send troops in or something or
you could send somebody a Stargate have
the first time they they dial into it
make it where they can't dial out again
or something and then just
I guess find a way to hack into it or
something and luckily the black hole as
a as the address yeah
be a wonderful Trojan Horse
you know using it as a weapon I think
the greater control you have over a uh a
DHD the more options you'll have you
know I don't think like starting a
command it didn't seem like it there was
a setup for all of those scenarios you
know all the things you could do because
they kind of had to step their way
through it imagine if you could isolate
one planet and redirect
their update file of four of the
positions of where everything's at and
just totally uh just totally hack their
database of addresses and just you could
create Havoc for a certain civilization
or destroy a certain civilizations uh
um Interstellar travel and you could
isolate you could cut them off from the
rest of the Galaxy by porting everything
if you had you know a really fine uh
detailed uh
control of their DHD
which I think because some because we
had to MacGyver a DHD basically I think
they have like an element of
understanding but at the end of the day
it took masses of computers yeah whereas
a DHD is a little thing size of a table
what all I would do is I would take the
Stargate a nearest of a wealthy Planet
sort of thing or something where a lot
of people come and go and I put at the
end of a cliff but I'd have it pointing
that way so as soon as you come through
slamming and I'll call it the lemming
planet
the living gate yeah the gold gold come
through oh bloody hell
yeah your technology is not going to
save you from Gravity so yeah
unless you go through in a um you know
like a little speeder or Darter or
something or like um Stargate infinity
and you've got your little
oh God that jumps through have you ever
watched anything no I almost did after I
finished SGU but I was like
no no uh the reason I didn't watch it
was because it's nowhere I don't even
think it's on Amazon anymore
I think you can get on DVD still maybe
but no I don't know if I wanted to pay
money for it nobody watched it first
time right but um
yeah they had a they had like um a sand
buggy thing what's the course we were
looking for like
why did Stargate come on never think of
that they only have every SG-1 Mission
they ever went on they had to they they
could only explore within walking
distance
why didn't they take a car
I mean not a full car but like a dune
buggy or something would be perfect yeah
that's what the infinity headlights of
doomberg yeah buggy like a little
four-person
the gate's pretty big you could put a
truck through it yeah easy
go for a drive it's like really really
throw some of these new civilizations
off all the medieval ones with cars
driving around when we went to the moon
the first thing they tried to do is how
can we take a car
you Americans are obsessed with cars we
are
we have the space we need a drive yeah
man you know the greatest place to drive
ever though it's a little traffic
until you get in the city
that was when I thought aluminum for
years was this special magic material
because um I think I've said this before
we had an Audi advert over here and it
was interviewing the guy that designed
the moon Boogie and he said we had to
create this aluminum and nobody ever
done it before and it's like oh my God
this aluminum sounds amazing I wonder if
it's like aluminum
um but those words are obviously spelled
differently so it can't be that oh no so
um because there's a whole I in there
you've forgotten about
so what else have we seen the star get
used for over its time other than a
transportation device and as a deadly
weapon
deadly weapon
um
it can be very deadly
yeah because you've been using The Time
Machine by accident
I mean
I know that the gate came through and it
hit like a solar flare and it come back
to 1969 but if you could figure out to
do that on purpose
that's not a bad way
to
again you could use it as a weapon or as
a research tool or as
um
you know it's for exploration really
couldn't you so all the above yeah it's
just how do you do it on purpose
carefully
uh
I genuinely don't like time travel
episodes in things
um I I thought Stargate did it okay
but
if if they could do on purpose and that
well also imagine that they actually
started using it as a time machine on
the show what do you think I would do to
the show
yeah I think that would kind of you can
either do like space travel like Star
Trek or you can do time travel like
Doctor Who but man mixing them up I'm
I'm trying to
I'm really trying to think of a series
that's done that well consistently as a
main theme
space travel and time travel I mean yeah
we've gotten burps here and there
through all sorts of series
you know um
well maybe it's not something they have
to do all the time either they could do
it for an arc like two or three episodes
or four episodes even for a longer one
and that could play out well because it
has a more of a focus than trying to
just make things work within certain
parameters
um
the ball is in your court that says
funny not always
a second ago
um
it's actually a time machine that makes
more logical sense than
um than normal time machines uh it does
room shows our company yeah that's true
um because I also think you know the
time machine from like um H.G Wells
they're saying well the Earth yeah
moving like 30 000 miles an hour and the
star that we're running is moving so if
you've got a time machine and you just
went back in time but didn't move you
would just reappear in space
um thousands of miles from the earth so
I think so it's a but the Stargate you
get sucked in by the gate don't you sort
of thing so you get so you get pulled in
by the gate so yeah the time machine is
probably the only one in sci-fi that
actually makes sense
but um so I mean it's logically
time machine
but I'm with you guys it would be just I
mean once by accident fine it's a fun
little thing but on purpose
you know a Stargate already has like an
element of time travel in it
because uh especially during the one
thing I noticed during the first few
seasons after this next last binge thing
is that they keep going back to Old
Earthen cultures yeah Egyptian or minoan
or whatever and it's like you start
getting all these flavors of
humans in the past and it is like kind
of like time travel I mean you do see
you know how these people live in
Earth's past but you know in
um
in present day like uh
uh when Sam has to wear this you know uh
Mongol burka kind of thing you know when
she's being traded around for um
stuff
you know but so you know you all you
still get the those elements of time
travel because you're going back to to
revisit ancient America
yeah
yeah but you get to see all these
ancient cultures and things because
they've not been touched by right anyone
fit that's just yeah that's a good point
um
can I go where was it
as well that is one of the things about
Stargate I love they've done a bit of
time travel
but they didn't do it like Star Trek you
can't just fly around the Sun really
quick and go back in time
because you would do that all the time I
I mean I if I was a captain of Starship
and I got up and I burnt my eggs I'd be
like to find who's flying around that
start I'm gonna go back to about 24
hours and I'm gonna have some nice eggs
you'd do it all the time
um but in Stargate they have the
sunspots thing so it was like impossible
to
uh you know know when it's going to
happen and the puddle jumper that they
destroyed
yeah much better way of doing it in
Stargate than um than Star Trek yeah if
my football team lost I'd be like don't
worry
yeah and
um and then we'll cheat so I think
attractive being my ball away and we win
um that zero seven day would never have
happened
oh Jesus God that's still I still get
comments on them bring it up didn't you
it was great
somebody clipped it and sent it whether
there was a clip deep skull going into
me just going
I'm getting more and more and then as
you can see at five mil I just gave up
like like something snapped to me the
soul is broken
um a couple of other things I thought
about well Matt who's not with us today
he last minute realized he couldn't he
couldn't get with us sorry
um he actually suggested using it as a
Lifeboat my Pen's going crazy it's kind
of cool
um
so [__]
think of a Star Trek anyway
um so he said about using it as a
Lifeboat so now Harris because you're a
heathen
but of course you don't really watch
Star Trek he's enough
um but mean stormy do remember the TNG
episode with the Dyson Sphere and Scotty
was in it Scotty from the original
series Mr Doon
um and he hid himself in the transporter
basically and he hid himself the
transporter buffer and it kept him alive
like 30 years or something uh
so Matthew wondered could Eli have done
that
I don't see why not yeah I mean he could
you know it's math boy himself even
smarter than Rush who's probably on the
same level as Sam and Rodney so
or he just committed murder unhook
somebody else threw them out of an
airlock took their space that have been
a lot easier I mean if you're going to
math it out
you know you have X pods and you need x
minus one pods you throw some ass all
out the door
I'd have eaten them
one at a time open kill them kill Rush
cut is that off
throw that out and then I'd just be
chewing on Rush
not the body let's just keep that around
us evidence well you might not want to
kill Rush he's too he's kind of
indispensable in his own way maybe just
two on some arms just chew on some arms
okay well you'd get you'd wake up with
no arms then because um but I'd be I'd
be sat there with a full belly guy go
and what would you have you been eating
steak
why haven't I got an ass rump steak
at the bottom of the round roast
actually
um
but um but yeah that's what I would do
but Eli could have done that potentially
he could have yeah obviously requires
reprogramming and verbally
um but but if you're able to do that my
other thoughts
oh no Seth just made a great point if
he's going to do that he might as well
just put himself in the Destiny's
computer
yeah but then what do you mean like is
um like like
um his girlfriend and Russia's
girlfriend I can't remember their names
at the top of my head
but are you really alive
not really and then they're kind of
trapped there indefinitely anyway so
they don't know if they ever can get
them out which is interesting so I'd say
go with the gate that that that's pretty
straightforward and if you can do the
math he can figure it out
I quite like my body
so uh when it used to work it used to
work it used to be great uh my my knees
were fine my back was fine no not so
much but um I'll be back around that Sun
real quick
what they really need is like is like a
solar flare gun that's orbital you know
so you it orbits at the right time and
you just you know engage the Stargate
then you pull the trigger on your solar
flare gun whenever you want to time
travel
you like the carnival all I'm saying is
at some point you're eating your friends
um you know it's just like I remember we
watched that I watched that film you
know the one where they they land in the
Andes and the football team and they
that was what I was just thinking about
uh
hell yeah I wouldn't just eat the dead
I'd start killing people if somebody's
there in the background and they're not
very useful like can you start a fire
I'm used to starting fires
so you're gonna add to how much meat we
have to eat per day so
I'm sorry they'll rescue me within 24
hours and I've eaten three people
I'll eat cow I'll eat a person I'm not
bothered I don't actually really see the
difference
um I might I might leave 24 hours
what is it people are supposed to be
very pork like like consistency wise and
and I don't know about flavor but you
can find that one out
I I think I feel this is an experiment
that's going to get us in trouble
okay yeah secular monk already said go
on full Donner party I see
um sounds about right
fun and some tasty it's um get great
crackling
um
uh New Guinea at some point
cooking tips
get some cooking tips
go back
I was thinking though if you can use it
as a Lifeboat could you use it as a
prison yes I was just thinking that ew
bacon uh but
you made me think of it uh earlier and
you stopped me which was good
why why not use the gate if we're using
it as as a as a placeholder or a prison
either or
just like
not the best thing to uh the quote
necessarily but Ant-Man quantumania had
King stuck down there for however long
you could essentially do the same thing
with Anubis
toss Anubis in there put him in prison
in a place where he actually can't do
anything
hmm
well we know that must be really useful
or Whitney in like a political prison
um
Anubis prior
as like you know a political prisoner he
could be useful Maybe
he could
yeah but also we know there's dimensions
yes another's International Space can a
wormhole only travel
to space and time or could it travel
through dimensions
well space time itself is a dimension so
it could technically travel through any
of these places it would just have to
rewire it to be able to do so or you
know if the mirrors can travel between
Dimensions you know surely you know what
if you had like you know some sort of
hybrid technology and a star mirror you
know where you could do either you could
you know anywhere in this Dimension any
gate in this Dimension or any other gate
in another dimension
mm-hmm yeah you know instead of like the
you know closing the Irish you just
engage the mirror and the mirror uh
comes in
[Music]
why not and in here and here just one
just one thing I I want to complain
about
um
yeah since you know I've been binging
right in the Stargate again uh SG-1
when when Daniel gets you know goes
through the mirror and everything he's
trying to find the right one and get
everybody back
would it have been so bad if the people
you know in the SGC put a sign up that
said Daniel this is the one and gave
like some you know put up like drawing
some picture or something random or they
would oh yeah that's that's that's where
I'm supposed to go instead of no is that
the right Carter no that's a captain can
I get if it just put a sign up says
Daniel come here
see that's something annual base that
decision on basically haircuts which
seem to be a cool choice I just wanted
to see them do that one they've all got
mustaches right next
um but the thing is Right a lot of the
dimensions if that dimensional space
there is correct would be very very
subtly different
so you could go through and think
everything would be exactly right but
Barney's red fine the dinosaur and
thinking it's just like he's red instead
of purple and like oh my God I'm in the
wrong freaking one but that's the only
difference and your your dimension is
now dead well and that totally could
have happened too because talking just
about dimensions and timelines etc etc
the Multiverse was most definitely there
at that moment so
did he go to the right one he could have
just gone to another dimension or
another Multiverse where Daniel had also
left that Multiverse and was looking for
his way home so would a sign even have
worked because then there could have
been infinite number of signs as well or
a few hundred thousand to go through
some random picture on it because it'd
been more you know if you're putting up
you know I don't know like it a Snoopy
cartoon or something maybe not all
universes would have that specific
Snoopy cartoon
think of it as you know thinking of it
as an interdimensional blockchain
I was like Seth just said we should
pitch this idea as this Interventional
thing
we kind of already did
so like nine eight about six no I've got
seven or eight months ago I did a little
Series where we talked about who would
the new villain be for Stargate and I
suggested the evil Ewoks
who are they which
I kind of like the idea of evil
Sasquatches just as much as evil Ewoks
well there you go but anyway the
furlings I said
a sequence of the furlings had been
imprisoned and we accidentally let him
out
um and and I I think that was a
brilliant idea but a lot of people
thought it was awful it's really
important thank you so much for the
contribution so it really helps out the
channel the Target Universe can always
count on the intervention of the
Ancients some of whom such as Merlin
Omar were willing to help Humanity those
which is damn right when if we got
ourselves into a real mess would
somebody like that pop down they're not
supposed to they're embargoed but
they do so whatever's necessary for the
story perhaps William
um yeah
but um I like the idea of it being used
as like a prison and
um and that like you said there that
maybe we're experimenting with the gate
and we open something
that we shouldn't and something does
come through
um
I like that yeah a little while ago
yeah the feelings were trapped in a
dimension so they're trapped in a pocket
of space was my idea and we accidentally
let them out
um and they no oh sorry they they got
they got themselves out when they asked
guard
in my idea the Asgard were The
Gatekeepers so they had the keys and
when they ask guards were gone
the furlings escaped that was my idea
and that was what I suggested
Anubis
Anubis was oh so let's just I think
we've we've we've whipped through that
really quickly to us in less than half
an hour that is everything you can be
used in the gate for so let's talk about
something else Anubis was way too
overpowered to be real fun for me
discuss
it's my favorite he yeah I mean he was
like uh
had everything going for him you know he
does get a little boring at times I
don't think they ever let him get too
too boring and they kind of like push
him to the side and let somebody else
come in and or let something else happen
uh to keep you entertained and intrigued
but I I can understand it Anubis is just
uh
he's he's um
all powerful in many ways like there's
nothing you really can do unless you
bring a war with the Ancients but you'd
have to almost start a war with them
just to get them to do anything about
him
which would be like a three-way War some
weird sense I don't know three-way okay
they did build in elements of weaknesses
didn't they because he didn't have a
Corporal body yes
he dissolved it basically from the
inside out so I mean there was elements
of weakness
um he was worried about the Ancients he
did build up quite slowly because he was
worried about
um the the system Lords at first
um but yeah he got past that quite
quickly
[Music]
um
so I I don't agree I think I for me it
was my favorite villain but I think
maybe maybe that's why they didn't use
him as much as maybe other villains
because he was overpowered and
but what were the aura
well okay I think with there is a
religious aspect to Anubis too but I
think the religious aspect of the aura I
helped them in their plot and and their
story kind of go forward a little bit
more Anubis was I loved him in the diner
uh but he he was too uh
oh I just had the whole thought in my
brain before I started talking and this
always happens
it's too early
um not really uh it's done I'm more down
the alcohol I'm leaving there you go uh
but but he he was too too um
what's the word I'm looking for
he he
he's not a deos ex machina he's he's uh
MacGyver a McGuffin now he was he's uh
I'm looking for something keep going
I'll come back to it I mean he was he
was because he was so powerful he could
it didn't matter
didn't any change that that's I guess
where uh his stuff nothing like a brain
fart I brain fart once a day it's it
happens
today
there's a lot going on upstairs sorry uh
but uh I I was thinking I feel like
where the aurai can
be pushed into a religion and and the
religion is very based off of the
Ancients they're essentially the
Ancients but like the cousins kind of
like the Asgard and the and the uh and
God Pegasus galleries Galaxy almost a
Prometheus Galaxy I was like that's not
right uh the Pegasus Galaxy Asgard
that's essentially what the URI are to
the Ancients and
there's just a a little different and
they're not so rooted and conceptualism
where Anubis was very conceptual
everything he did was a a concept it had
to have some scientific thing that or
some religious aspect to some sciency
thing to put it into place where the
aurai were walking amongst us and could
interact with us on a physical level at
any time and then do their weird creepy
stuff
does that make sense kind of just
because yeah yeah the thing I liked
about the aura and the Asgard and then
the aura are probably the least favorite
we get comments about Seasons nine and
ten quite a lot and it's if sg1 went off
a hill it went off the cliff in season
nine
um they jump the shark and things like
those comments when you like the aura
but I liked that the actual the only
difference between the Ori and the
ancients
was that the aura I thought they should
interfere with
humanity and the Ancients thought they
shouldn't other than that there isn't
really a difference between them they
weren't evil for Evil's sake
you know Italy they just people kneeling
Downton
hyper narcissist
yeah
they're bad I guess their biggest bad
trait was that they thought in a similar
pattern as the the Google did a Gould
they just wanted uh people to worship
them and I guess it did give them more
power so it's similar in certain ways of
course because their power is more
of spiritual I guess than the ghou old
who oh yeah we just have a bunch of
people now
[Music]
they kind of they're a little bit
Shadow Babylon five I kind of get that
the or I would
it's just Uber powerful I do understand
what people don't like the all right but
the thing was the chick from Firefly was
in it and I love her very much so bloody
black
oh yeah I'm Claudia Black was in it and
I love her very much as well and I just
love that when she went for the
interview for that do you think they
just sort of went do you mind wearing
almost constant leather and Claudia
Black was like okay
I mean I thought she was great her
bouncing off Daniel was some of my
favorite stuff and stuff oh my God right
I think that's that's really the my
favorite part of all of Seasons nine and
ten is is Daniel and Valor and I I do
like uh uh Cameron Ben browder's
character I like him a lot but yeah
um
I got your name for a minute I have to
admit I did forget her name for a second
um I don't think the Stargate producers
we're we're just doing questions from
the from the audience now yeah we burned
through the um I thought we'd be talking
about those Stargate thing for ages and
we just didn't so but that's the fun of
doing it like
from the Firefly necessarily what they
were good at though was any if Stargate
if any sort of sci-fi show got canceled
they were sort of like cherry picking oh
we like that guy
yeah but I mean since we're going back
to you know comments from the uh chat
room popcorn power had one it was way
Upstream he said um talking about you
know the the blockchain trying to get
and Daniel to or the SGC to put up some
unique signs So Daniel could hone in on
it and so popcorn said um yes but all
the other universes would be putting up
a sign saying Daniel this one here
that's true but I got an idea how you
could get around that
yeah that's it so what you know they all
had the the uh the going through the
gate they had to dial in uh device you
know where they could you know produce a
signal in the in the and
it would open the iris
well what if you had a seated
um number generator much like you know
OCT you know if you're in busy and you
work for a big OCTA you know you have to
punch in a certain number and it has to
be reflective of the other computer
always already has that number unstored
so what if we just had some device you
just got to pick the one that matches
your code your code on your arm
you see and therefore you couldn't have
probably couldn't have the same code
because they're both seeded to it
they're like entangled in kind of a
manner yeah yeah it'd almost be like a
dial Home device right so you have a or
the you know the the thing we had to
open up the IRS
and randomly generated and Bubba yeah
and but then you would have to actually
be physically like you said if it was
somehow and Tangled or something so it
was actually physically connected
um yeah because I thought that my first
instinct was only the universe that
you're in that you will have asked to do
this time but actually if we're talking
about an infinite universe
you'll have done that an infinite amount
of times there will be a load of
universes where you've done exactly the
same thing
um but I can't get my head around
infinite
so I think that's a mathematical thing
it can't actually be infinite I think
there's there's a really good I think
it's Netflix there's a documentary on
Infinity
it'll bend your brain it'll bend your
brain
just Infinity in general I thought
you're saying there's a documentary on
Stargate Infinity
documentary on the the concept of
infinity and it'll break your brains you
have a couple pints then hit play
they think even space isn't infinite
it's it's I saw one thing they said it's
horseshoe shaped I'm like what
[Music]
do horseshoes
in the one theory is that if you travel
for long enough in the same direction
eventually you'll end up my query
started
um
or of horseshoe shaped but so I can't
get my head around infinite I just can't
it's you know it's not it's not a
concept it's like somebody started
talking to me about the concept of
nothing
and it's so fundamental to science that
that nothing is is you know we base
everything but actually if you start
thinking about what is nothing well from
your brain well well there is no such
thing as nothing technically uh that's
what I I I read something last year I
don't remember what it was but there's a
group of people that subscribed to
nothing is just quantum foam and it's
something that we haven't really learned
how to even quantify or comprehend for
yet of course it's it's hard to even
start thinking about that kind of stuff
but nothing is technically just quantum
foam which is endless in a way
there's an article I think is on new
scientists uh yesterday concerning this
very thing about you know the lack of
nothing and quantum foam and how
everything is entangled you know and
um it goes back into current research
saying that you know black holes some of
them can be immune to heat death
well if there's something that can be
immune to heat death in the universe
well that just dude that rewrites
everything I mean the Large Hadron
Collider at CERN really gave a lot of
people just migraines
yeah because I mean it's it's
fascinating and you know the data is the
data but it really upended everything we
know it's just like
um
like I don't like uh he was saying it's
you know there's no such thing as
nothing because the you know the quantum
foam and it's like if you have any kind
of random Square uh or cubic meter of
space or maybe one hydrogen or one
helium atom in it
but then it's also chock full We Now
understand of quantum foam or Quantum
you know Quantum particulates and it's
like those don't you know we can fly as
fast as we can through them or we fast
as we want through them with no fear of
impact
so what are they made out of it's it's
like water but not but it's like water
but not you know and so it's uh I mean
this it is it's not reading such a new
science and it's such new ideas and new
ways of how to think of things that yeah
migraines all the way around well we
just got two good comments sets that our
universe is inside of oh I didn't read
that one actually I was two two above
that it was Lewis said a lot of things
to think about and you can't understand
the mind of God
all right shall we throw a wrench in it
just quantum foam I don't necessarily
subscribe or adhere to this Theory but
Quantum phone just thinking about it is
if nothing is really not nothing and it
is something and it's just something
that we haven't Quantified or
comprehended fully
could quantum foam
just be pixels in a way in our Matrix
are we in a matrix is that why nothing's
not really nothing
and then obviously this is a whole
another little sci-fi route to go down
but if we know nothing's not nothing
it's the universe dissecting the quantum
particles to see what they're made out
of I mean it's a rabbit hole you know oh
yeah oh and it was a comment
um
uh by chilling in the basement zero was
invented by India I could swear it's
invented by Bank of America because they
keep reminding me of this year
this is going to be the smartest comment
ever
have a math Concept in your bank account
please
um eradicate this constant and put some
freaking money in right
um Brahma guptra yeah Brahma Gupta is
brilliant mathematician
yes it wasn't that even that long ago
because 1600 years ago something is it
four fifth century or something
yeah all that was when Europe was you
know burning women at the stake for
being witches you know the the actually
during the Dark Ages in Europe uh
Baghdad was the center of scholarly
research and Academia on Earth
you know the uh
the the amount of uh knowledge that they
gained and pushed forward in terms of
astronomy biology physics uh just
mathematics alone is really something to
Marvel at what one-third of our stars in
the sky all have Arabic names
you know and
um
Lots I mean and also in India a lot of
the places that weren't burning people
at the stake was really you know uh
cradling uh Science and Mathematics
um
yes
yes right
uh uh it wasn't Anubis was it oh no see
she did it twice didn't she once you
destroyed two stars
I think she yeah she she's got two on
her list oh
um one was the name this one was uh um a
fleeter
ships wasn't it
can I throw an idea pasture that it's a
video I'm working on yeah for this week
and I want to throw and this is going
back to Stargate a little bit but right
so Jenny stiven was on dial the gate
last night
and one thing she was talking about was
the new Citadel TV series
um a lot of people have been saying it
bombed it cost 250 million dollars and
it bombed and it didn't
it's a nonsense it did really really
well all over the world it's very very
well in India I mean like very well
it just didn't do very well in America
and Amazon don't really care about that
because they've started to realize
actually the international audience they
basically realized that more people live
in the rest of the world than live in
America they did some math they were
like the zero but that's a concept so
we'll just forget about that and then
we've got yeah there's like so they
realize there's more people
they realize that a billion people in
China is bigger than than America so um
so they're saying that Amazon might be
looking at that model for Stargate
so what she was basically suggesting was
you could have a Stargate series
that's based in
um
America you know at in Colorado but then
you could also have a series that is
related to it
an insane universe but maybe based in
India filmed in Indian I think one of
the things I thought was like you could
have like the three or fours you could
have a serious base to board of Chinese
304 which we saw
um they all speak Chinese it's a show
for China but it's in our universe and
it and it affects they'll affect each
other something
is that something you'd want to see
actually
anywhere else besides China yes
there's 1.5 billion people they're going
to want to well the India one
for damn sure uh because they have
dancing
yeah
all these dancers coming out of Stargate
you know
that
yeah all that business yeah
it'd be great
I would just break out into a dance
what's your dance
um but this is what they do with Citadel
they've got the main series and then
there's going to be
um like the Indian office version and
there's going to be a couple of others
so
um but they're all going to be in the
same universe we're all going to affect
each other but I was thinking this could
be perfect because then a series could
be pulled back
to
um you know like the movies could link
them all or something yeah there's so
many ways they could do this
but that got me started thinking about
is
Hollywood
becoming irrelevant
well
I think Hollywood has been Irrelevant
for some time
you know uh it's just lots of money in
Hollywood but in terms of artistry and
storytelling uh back in the I guess it
was the 90s maybe the
late 80s early 90s there's a thing you
could probably Google this or maybe it's
in Wikipedia uh called for Chinese
filmmaking called fifth generation
Chinese filmmaking
and
um
it was a series it was a it was a kind
of a generation of filmmakers
that was making some of the best films
uh that I've ever seen
raise the Red Lantern is an example
um
and they did it with like no money at
all you know and you know with
with and I think without little with
very little uh government intervention
and even these days the uh Studios
interfere with Productions American
Studios interfere more with Productions
than the Chinese government interferes
with Chinese filmmakers if that doesn't
boil your blood I don't know what will
but just yeah I don't think Holly I mean
Hollywood's a big machine but it's only
a big machine because it's got a lot of
money not a lot but it's got a lot of
talent that said all the the like um
The Guns of the world and all of that
they're still great filmmakers but
they're under more men under more
supervision with uh their production
companies and their Studios then I it's
just a personal feeling then the Chinese
government gave the people of the fifth
generator or the yeah the fifth gen uh
filmmaking movement it's not just your
personal opinion because in 2016 China
passed a law the banned all content that
was deemed to be harmful to the dignity
and honor of the interests of the
People's Republic of China
so I mean that's the Vegas law you've
ever heard but no Chinese filmmakers
have been able to make anything that's
deemed to be harmful to the dignity and
honor or interests
of China
sorry well one of the first things they
did which pissed people off right after
that was they take black people off the
posters they took Finn John boyega off
of all the Star Wars posters they didn't
allow him on the posters and he's like
90 of the force awakens and of course
his role gets lessons as it goes on but
they did that all over the place and
that's that's sad it's not right it's
just not also what's what's the point
today and not have black people in China
that could be a whole different
conversation
they may not have a very large
black or African African African Chinese
population because he didn't have the
um
migration that we had obviously I mean
we have a Chinese population in here in
America because of a migration out of
China not in
um so but but what how would that affect
you know
the the dignity or their thing to see
like all those black people they exist
what
um you know it's like I don't I don't
get it I don't get it I don't get why
but they left him in the film
yeah you can't edit around all that but
but there are like you can edit around
and cut some scenes out from across the
uh globe and they have done that uh I
did that for Star Wars but I wouldn't be
surprised
it's sad look at the Hong Kong movie
industry yeah he is doing some of the
greatest martial arts movies we've ever
seen
um you know that's where Bruce Lee made
his best films with gold
um and obviously now that's gone
band done adios
but um I just wonder whether
Hollywood's time has been is the
dominant Force probably in World
entertainment which I think is fair to
say that has been since the 20s
um maybe a bit later than that because I
mean British Cinema was pretty strong
until pretty much
maybe the early 50s
um
now
the rest of the world has Cinemas
whereas maybe they didn't 20 years ago
they have a disposable income which
maybe they didn't have 20 30 years ago
you know like um China's wealthy and
developed and and all of a sudden
nobody wants to watch dub TVs they watch
their own and okay what they need to
make was crap but now what they make is
actually pretty good yeah and you know
they
they're being taken over I think about
films like um I think was it called
Great Wall with Matt Damon a few years
ago yeah
now that was a bad film yeah but it was
a first try at doing something that
never really been done before and that's
making amazing film with an American
actor So in theory they do that all the
time Arnold Schwarzenegger has been
making those movies for two decades
they're that that's that's a frequent
thing
to the point of the great wall though
where no that was like big big budget
version of it and it was a big big fail
I guess because of it because at the
same time it's one of the big issues
with sorry so it didn't make any sense
it was virtually in comprehensible you
could it was almost watchable well
that's the thing with Marvel and uh Star
Wars even to a degree Star Wars
thankfully has such a rich universe that
it can kind of stay within its own uh uh
well of information and culture and all
that kind of stuff but Marvel's really
didn't push back where
hey if you have to appease everybody
nobody's really gonna love it you're
gonna annoy everyone here
and and you can't make a film for
everybody there's gonna be groups of
people that don't like your film and
that's okay
but you got to make the story at hand
that you want to tell and and I think
trying to dilute those stories down is
what's put us in this kind of space but
but I don't know I don't think
Hollywood's gonna die necessarily I just
think the competitions here and I think
it's a great thing I think there should
be more competition New York's huge uh
London's huge Vancouver is huge all
these places are huge but now there's
Bollywood and tollywood both in India
because India is larger than China
population wise now that happened in the
last census
uh where I think China's is not down to
where because lat two sentences ago or
whatever it was 1.1 billion in India and
1.4 in China I think it's like 1.3 in
China now uh because they've just been
going down and then India's like
1.456 or something like that when you
don't let your population have more than
one child feel good they desperately
needed to do
um India just like now religion we don't
we don't yeah but but India has
Bollywood and tollywood which are
getting bigger and bigger bollywood's
really like India's thing tollywood is
their International kind of more version
of things that's the film like RR is
Hollywood not Bollywood uh stuff like
that so there are some differences but
then Jenny Steven brought it up
yesterday and and the the gate World
down the gate stream which made me super
happy she talked about Nollywood
Nigeria's newest uh uh filmmaking kind
of thing English there's yes because we
only gave it back a few years ago yeah
but Nigeria is the fastest growing
country on the planet like they can they
could bring out some cool stuff Nigeria
back eight years here's something that
you know that is really democratized
filmmaking is now you just go get you
know a fancy um uh Apple laptop and
um
get it Adobe
and you're off of the races there's
nothing you can't do
literally I mean most like
um I was watching one of the uh special
features of one of the Marvel movies and
they're they're editing the whole thing
in Adobe Premiere no no specialized no
fifty thousand dollar Suite of tools it
was just Adobe Premiere
um and it's 55 bucks a month for all the
tools yeah and so the the cost of
filmmaking has really come down I mean
you can you know shoot AK for nothing I
mean aren't there some you know uh
aren't there uh in there a Samsung phone
and now shoots 8K
I don't know about that but or one
that's all that one's been announced or
something but I mean a AK simple these
days almost
yeah sort of kind of we're still
streaming on 720p but you know I I've
been trying to piss off stream yards
just a little bit to at least let access
to to better versions of streaming
obviously it can
halt the stream but
yeah please don't dis stream yard
damn it it's not like did you see the um
you know the podcast guys
um they did a video where they um they
really slagged Amazon off and they got
demonetized within about an hour
um if they said it was within 90 minutes
they were like no I'm not saying this
conspiracy but hello I'm hoping they get
monetized really quickly again but um
but it was a little bit ironic that was
like that was quick I mean Amazon
uh excuse me YouTube them
okay Captain k hey man has done another
thing Hollywood is running everybody
isn't doing nothing but repeat movies
something that Jenny's diving again said
yesterday we've got the prequel recall
and what's a recall when they just redo
stuff they've done before and stormy I
don't know how you feel about this mate
but new track is it just one long recall
well they're just redoing traffic
you know I maybe different flavors of
track I was thinking this last week I
was thinking about this uh question
ironically but it was like Star Trek
discovery
was like a lot of Star Trek stories
but there it was always ended in like
some sort of uh
uh therapy session
you know it was just like oh we
understand and now we accept you it was
there was a lot of that so it's like
it was this it was the therapy version
of Star Trek and then you know Brave New
worlds is almost a shoot em up again
and so yeah I think there's lots of
different themes these shows have
it's all still Star Trek selling this
big huge world but they they they tell
similar stories of exploration and
whatnot and conflict but all with a
different flavor and I think Star Trek
Discovery was kind of fair you know had
a lot of therapy moments of therapy
moments of therapy scattered throughout
the story I'm watching like strangely
wills at the moment so I've got a video
coming out about it this week I've seen
I'm not gonna argue that actually I just
think they're making remake in the
original series episodes well the the
last episode was I'm not watching this
is Roddenberry Star Trek all over this
this is if this is so Roddenberry
um
um we will talk about the stroke now
because I think
these people need these people those
people uh writers and actors and
everything well you calling these people
I know I actually generally had somebody
scream at me once because I I said them
when I was talking to somebody who are
them because well them they're very
important those people over there and so
she ended up crying
um okay but um
so
ask I forgot what I was saying but I I
watch Picard season three though and I'm
like you've just watched Star Trek
nemesis
and um and Star Trek first Contact and
you've just jiggled it about
and um and made a new series I'm like
I'm watching a lot of Star Trek and I'm
thinking I've seen this before and how
many other movies and things have we
seen in the last 20 years you think
this is very familiar
you know change the names
and you know the setting and I'm like
I'm so sure this is why I made the
argument with the AI that actually I
think AI could recreate 80 of what we
see at the moment because I don't think
it's that creative
I mean well yeah the the solid 80 20
rule you know uh 80 of or 20 of your
movies are gonna
pay for 80 of what you actually do and I
think it's kind of almost vice versa
where 80 of what studios are doing are
those safe routes it's for equals
reboots franchises IPS big things that
they know are going to do something yeah
and then that that the 20 now is like
the small budget stuff that's like
creative and interesting and and that's
why horror movies I think are doing
better than most
other genres because they're the only
things where like sure you're going to
rehash like the same 15 20 little things
almost every time maybe if maybe bigger
than that there might be 30 50 different
things that are like your general troops
of horror movies but there's so many
ways to mix and match those and you can
be creative in any way of that and then
make a little sci-fi horror make a
little uh a horror during the daylight
in the middle of Sweden or something
like midsomar is terrifying but in a
different way because it's not like it's
more of a thriller in a lot of ways I
think that genre is really doing it
right and it would be nice if a lot of
these other genres would focus on that
sci-fi's always been very good about
that there's still a small budget Sci-Fi
movies last year you remember uh Ryan
Johnson of All Peoples uh he he was uh
leading the uh
interview for Vesper remember we did the
that Vesper review and investor was a
great little sci-fi movie not a huge
budget
decent cast it did exactly what it
should I think sci-fi and horror are
really
a good North Star for for where things
should go I guess and have always been
in a lot of ways and I think they remain
that
Hollywood generally thinks
we have got the attention span of Dory
from bloody um that fish Pixar movie
which one I've got the name of finally
Nemo
okay
sequels and that's the thing um but
actually are they right
oh I mean
Instagram yells yeah so I I think you
know I think they are uh sequels are
easier to sell it's easier to get
somebody in the seat if it's a sequel if
they enjoy the original movie you know
especially if you've got kids and you
want to throw them
um Finding Nemo three oh well that'll
keep the Little Tikes entertained for
two hours so you bundle ever trundle
everybody off to the theater to watch it
you know it's always an easier sell if
somebody's already a fan of it
uh the the problem with sequels of
course is usually they are not as good
as the original very rarely do they get
better oh well back that up with
evidence
so you can't just make random statements
like sequels and Never As Good As the
original without backing it up with some
evidence and I will just follow aliens
damn it
I don't have any of this that's
literally the only one I can think of
Terminator
2.0 but usually the sequels are
typically almost always
what was that there was a one that was
just really bad I think it was like a uh
for Superman the first one with Chris
Reed Christopher Reeves was it yeah
probably yeah it was it was just yeah
I don't know the second one was I was
argued the second is at least as good
but then Prasad and everything
[Music]
um I would say that was easily as good
as the original but then the third one
this one that went through a Stargate on
the edge of a cliff
um
but yeah generally speaking
sequels are not as good but have they
booked that Trend in the last few years
yeah a little bit
well I mean you know I thought the the
first Standalone
um
some of the standalone
Marvel movies for specific characters
or the first ones were good the second
one's kind of lacked
you know with the ones with them
huh Iron Man 2 is pretty forgettable
Thor two Ant-Man two
yeah yeah
had a great number too
yeah and number three I think the
Captain America's have got better
they're the best Trilogy by far I think
out of all the Marvel stuff yeah
um Richard is just saying it may be
pretty much the only movie that's gonna
make any money at the cinema this year
at the moment Mission Impossible
um when it's horror movies
yeah it's just it's
a Toy Story
yeah second one you know Blade Runner
2049 was
I mean I liked it but it did not stand
up to the original but it all the
original brought out everything you know
it created the entire world
and then in 2049 they got to play in it
so the nice polish of all the the whole
all the new ideas that was in the
original
well it's still there but you don't have
new ideas you just have a drama set with
a specific uh bit uh collection of
Storytelling rules this is the thing you
know this is a replica this is this and
this is the that and this so you've
already learned that from the first
movie so you don't get any of that new
stuff you just get the drama and the
interaction based on it so a lot of
times I think that's I mean it's still a
great movie I loved it I bought it but
it was it was not there wasn't a lot of
new stuff yeah
I think there's a difference as well
between some films that are popular so
they have to do a sequel and they feel
like they have to do it really quickly
that was always the the biggest mistake
back in the day we've got to do this
morning and we've got to do it within
two years because people will forget why
they like the original and I ever go no
we can remember three years it's it's
fine I could I can even remember four
not much more than that because kovid
messes with me after that yeah yeah okay
but um but but there's a difference I
think between films like that and then
films that are always designed to be a
Trilogy I mean you could argue The
Godfather was always going to be that
trilogy
um I can't think of any others off top
of my head Lord of the Rings Lord of the
Rings was always going to be that so
that they stand up with each other but
they're not really sequels are they
there they're they're they're three
parts of a storybook
sorry
one book yeah
Harry Potter just got better because it
went along Harry Potter
but yeah Harry Potter
um but I mean but when films that I
always think the RoboCop is the is the
is the most is the most annoying example
of this is it the robocopted much better
than they thought it was going to do so
they rushed with RoboCop too and I don't
hate RoboCop 2 I actually think it's an
okay movie
but there was a plan for RoboCop too the
original writer wrote
um the story for it but he couldn't get
it finished in time so they went with a
different script
this is just stupid
they're now planning to make that script
yeah that's that may be the that maybe
what everything we're gonna do they're
going to make 14 years later
but I mean
does Hollywood just think we're a bunch
of idiots and are they partly right I
mean yes they've always thought that and
they've been 100 right the entire time
what what did TVs I mean what is the
technical definition or term for TV
television
programming like the whole point has
been to program I mean they call it a
program
it's pretty straightforward they don't
try to hide anything you know they've
always thought we were pretty easy to to
sway and
that they have with news with television
with the different arrows of TV with the
different eras of film
uh it's it's pretty easy to sway a
public if there's some big focal point
for that public to focus on you know
sorry go ahead no no no that's about it
I was just gonna say Insidious
historically as always have always uh
underestimated the audience
you know we will you know we enjoy and
we'll accept much more complicated
stories and things that are kind of
really out there
um Kubrick oh my right just one word
you know
um it's like you know all the um
the executives that were you know for
the first Star Wars movie they were just
yeah just give Lucas anything let's just
get it done because they thought this
was what the hell is this mess he did
such a good job you know
with with uh
earlier and then he comes up with what's
this the the sith's what yeah let's just
get it over with let's finish it's just
it'll be yeah and then you know they
totally underestimated the audience and
now he's a billionaire
because they just gave away all the
rights to everything
just to kind of you know get it done
does he underestimated the audience like
there's nothing there's no value here
you know Lucas is coming up with some
crazy thing
you know then there's just no value in
what he's making so let's just give it
all away what a rule to lose the
audience and lost
generally speaking though
I think they have been Executives know
that if they make a sequel to something
that's going to be popular it will make
money and generally they're right
but are we now seeing
that people have actually smartened up
and they've actually realized that no I
want to see something different
uh
the studios shot themselves in the flood
by just being so gung-ho about all the
streaming stuff I I think what was it
Mark the other day was talking about it
with you on the your interview uh for
the shuttlepot stuff was they shot
themselves in the foot by the what was
wrong with the TV landscape at the time
nothing Netflix was a lone outlier and
they an outlier they were they were
popular but they weren't nearly as
popular as they are now they're more
popular now because of the entire
industry has kind of circumvented
themselves to deal with what Netflix's
model is and now these strikes are
essentially about that too which is a
whole different scenario uh not really
that different of course they kind of
play into the same things but it's all
correlative and they they really the
studios at least shot themselves on the
foot by going all gung-ho on streaming
well I wonder if it you know when
Netflix when they came out with stranger
things
it seems like that was some sort of you
know seismic shift and everything it's
like holy [__] that show was popular
maybe we should you know this another
streaming service is probably we should
do something else they've really got
this thing I didn't know there was that
much interest in [__] you could do on
streaming alone you know well stranger
things wasn't even first remember House
of Cards was first and House of Cards
was talk about a seismic shift in TV
people just were like let's do that
let's let's do that
there's the House of Cards was just like
I mean I think they just watched West
Wing and thought we just need to get
more effects West Wing with [__]
yeah well more [__] right you could
argue it's like West Wing but actually
let's do what people actually are like
because all everyone in West Wing was
just like what can we do for the country
and reality is what can I do for myself
and
um and you know Kevin Spacey
well we won't mention him
terrible human being amazing actor
wonderful performances but you got to be
crazy to get that crazy uh uh portrayed
that well I guess
there is a big thing isn't it um yeah
the craziest crazy yeah really well
um there's a lot of actors out there
that are complete dicks but what are you
gonna do but I I think I agree I I just
think that you know Executives think
we're stupid and far too often they're
right because they will try to release
something that's phenomenally brilliant
and nobody watches it or takes or takes
too long
for us to tweak that it's great
and it skips by and if something isn't
makes the money immediately they cancel
it yeah it's a problem isn't it that
worries me itself just thinking about
the stream from yesterday with Jenny and
it was one of the things that I I didn't
necessarily like that she said was well
she didn't necessarily say it either she
was like I'm waiting until the unions
tell me to say something or something
like that uh was to that they might tell
us to stop going to the movie theaters
and
I I just don't agree with that at all
because a lot of the times even the big
theaters I mean the the the big movies
uh more so
with with higher level actors even
mid-level actors a lot of the time the
smaller budgets they still get a
percentage of the film after the fact so
if these people are not getting jobs
they're not getting paid they're not
working for the next eight nine ten
months those going to go see those
movies is the only way to put money in
their pockets and if you're gonna go see
the big movies with the big actors those
are the people donating to the funds of
of the the insurance funds for sag and
for the wga those are the people putting
money in the pockets of all the other
writers and all the other actors the
smaller fish that can't do that and the
only way to give them more money to do
that is to go see their movies so I
think that was a little bit of a an
oxymoron in that sense the one yesterday
from gate World dial the gate
um stream that's not talking about the
thing and what they were basically
saying was there were some ideas
knocking around the writers and Screen
Actor skills that maybe they would ask
people to not go to the cinema to really
hurt the studios
I would argue that doesn't just hurt the
studios though it also hurts the cinemas
um the economic landscape of film and TV
in general yeah
one of our biggest cinema chains in the
UK just went under literally like last
week or week before
um and before that cineworld which is
the second biggest
um I had to shut a load down and got
bought out
um Odin are the only ones that have sort
of going and a lot of our sort of like
independent Cinemas closed
going back to what Harris was saying you
know it's
um
covert was a bad enough thing for
Cinemas you know and those that did
survive still struggling you know
because you know we were talking during
the in you know talking about when we're
talking about Indiana Jones is like most
of my co-workers they were just gonna
wait for streaming you know they didn't
want to be bothered by going to the
theater you know when I went like
opening weekend there was hardly anybody
in the theater there wasn't hardly
anybody in the cinema at all I mean
there was the parking lot was mostly
empty on a Saturday morning well noonish
and when when the parking lot for an
entire Cinema Plex is mostly empty for a
Saturday matinee
that's there's you know and you're not
in the middle of comfort you've recover
from God that's really really bad
financial news for a lot of people
something that somebody said to me that
I find really interesting today was um
has Disney shut themselves in the foot
because they've started putting their
movies on Disney plus too quickly
oh yeah we'll just think
why should I go to the cinema it'll be
on Disney Plus in a month
because it was I mean
um black widow was on at the same time
they put it behind a paywall initially
but then it was on within a few weeks
Avatar way of water is already on it on
Disney Plus
that that took a long time though that
took I didn't I think it was that long
oh no no no James Cameron made sure of
it it was in theaters for at least what
it released was it the last of November
or first week of December
yeah I mean he was in the theaters for a
long time but uh yeah four or five
months
yeah but then within us within a few
weeks of it not being at Cinema though
it's on Disney plus oh yeah and you do
want to do that though uh because you
want more eyes on it usually I I think
there there were two or three weeks
leeway where there were some uh uh DVD
sales because James Cameron is good he's
one of the people that's still very good
about saying we need the time let it sit
DVD then put it wherever you want to put
it but because it went to some it went
to some pay cable company was it HBO
that it went first not not online but
you had to have the cable subscription
the old school came HBO
and then it was on there for a few weeks
I think or maybe a month and then there
was then it went to uh streaming and
then DVD or
I ordered it you know you know I bought
it off of Apple Plus
um early on I mean I may have bought it
but it didn't get delivered until all
ever it's been seen everywhere but uh
apples doesn't work
I think I bought it before like a few
weeks before it started streaming
I wouldn't want to watch Renfield with
them with um Nick Cage and I'm not going
to pay for it it's still 12 pounds it's
gone down from 20. it's now 12.
um but I'm not paying for it but one
because Harris told me it's not how damn
it I did it so well earlier uh Harris is
called me lower your expectations
something like that but I must know the
second I pay for it it will be on Bloody
Netflix
okay so I'm not doing it I bought the
nice guys on DVDs the last DVD I ever
bought was the nice guys and literally
the day I got home with it and I got I'm
gonna I'm looking forward to this I'm
gonna watch nice guys and I sat down and
I turned the TV on and the first advert
on Netflix was that the nice guys are
premiered it's like damn it
oh my God I don't mind spending money I
hate wasting money I hate it I hate it I
hate it but don't think about it like
that at least you have a digital library
being built up that that is it's
physical media is gone I feel like
digital libraries are nice in a way
because especially right now I've got
1200 DVDs sat in the garage that I now
never look at all right we'll put them
puppies on a disc and put them on your
computer somehow
Matthew said that I'm like I don't even
know how but anyway me either but he can
help you he could help you and then
donate him to your local library
because one day they'll be retra
um I'm just doing extra copy put on a
little uh uh uh one drive there we go
that's the word I'm looking for and then
us as I'm ready to finish the stream now
anything you just want to throw out to
annoy me
oh let me well
no we did get to everything that I was I
was saving up for you know
um
the thing about yeah well crap now I
don't I can't think of anything else
right now right so thank you so so much
for everybody in the comments thank you
so much for the couple of people that
dropped um
I think it's k-rod that came up with
something it was a really good idea
she's talking or they were talking about
you know an SGC on the moon and find out
the Moon is hollow right but it gave me
an idea for uh
all Roman numeric movies put together go
they gave me an idea you know for a new
SG spin-off wouldn't it I don't think
he's coming back but wouldn't it be cool
if there was like you know a whole
spin-off on like the alpha side you know
all the [__] that goes on is just the
alpha side yeah because it's a much more
unfiltered environment than you know the
uh the SGC and it seems like it'd be
more you know uh more Frontier more uh
rough and tough maybe because they are
for the frontier aspect of things yeah
where the SGC started like that and now
it's kind of like okay we'll send people
over here we'll we'll do whatever we
need to we're the alpha site can
actually like continue exploration
but they can
go out and Venture I know it'd be cool
wouldn't it you know I like it because
then you're all you're not operating you
know all the the formalities you know
with a general Hammond or whatever you
know you're you're it's
um you have to make a lot of split
decisions on your own and you know not
without the support of all the toys of
Earth you know you're you're kind you
know so I think it'd be a lot of
interesting storytelling if you just do
a show based on the alpha side what do
you think there uh Jamie
I think I've had a lovely week so we can
go for another 10 minutes if you want
but
um I saw the um I saw that comment as
well and I thought if Roland Denmark is
allowed to do the star game we'll get a
freaking Hollow Moon yes aliens and
they'll be called the Anunnaki and uh
there'll be lizard people in it and
every other bloody Ancient Aliens theory
that gets knotted around by that idiot
with a big hair
um at some point somebody will say it's
not aliens
it's aliens
I like the idea I I like when we talked
earlier about this like um International
Stargate thing we were talking about
this scene a Stargate
um
style thing that there'd be lots of
different shows potentially going on at
once I love the idea of some of them
being based in different languages
different cultures different others or
things for them but influences us so
it'd be on Netflix we watch Spanish TV
now anyway
um I'm horribly dyslexic I don't really
want to read my television but I I would
if it's done it but having something
like on an alpha site
yeah why not
um I love the idea of an alpha site I
love the idea of an ancients prequel I
love the idea of a show being based on
one of the 304s or 305s or 306s whatever
we have at that point
um so we could have
I mean
Star Trek have done it so why not why
don't we have a you know a Multiverse
sorry a TV show that actually explores
the actual Universe don't do what Star
Wars didn't have every damn episode on
Tatooine don't do what Star Trek does
and have we're on about a fourth Captain
Kirk at the moment we don't need to do
that actually get out there and explore
the universe actually take advantage
of a franchise without redoing rehashing
we bloody doing it all just for all of
that we've got a Star Wars Episode and
nobody mentioned Luke Skywalker for five
minutes I don't give a [__] just I wanna
there's there are other people out there
let's explore it you see I I think
you're right I think you're supporting
uh uh Harrison nice idea of Fast and
Furious on Tatooine
with George Lucas they did that
Vin Vin Diesel has to go save Jar Jar
Binks but it turns out Jar Jar Binks is
Darth jar jar so be prepared we are fan
picking this like nobody's business
we've already have Fast and the Furious
on Tatooine though because that was the
whole
little Anakin movie yeah but we didn't
have Vin Diesel though
was pretty bald though
that's true
yeah
um that's a pop comparison that we'd get
tired of that approach really quickly I
don't think we would I it I I I I think
it we either would absolutely love it or
it would be so annoying from like the if
if the first spin-off was annoying then
it would be awful uh but if
something
we wouldn't watch a lot of them I'm
probably going to watch Stargate India
I'm probably not going to watch it the
point is it's it's a Stargate show for
India so you maximize the potential of
the show
I probably won't watch a Stargate show
that's that's not in English well okay
that's that's where my question will
probably go next is
like like they said yesterday it was
like hey they speak English over there
they speak English in all these places
are they gonna do these big old IP shows
in English in another country are they
going to do it in their local language I
think I think in their local language
but it'll be set in the same universe
but in if it's International isn't the
easiest way to go just English because
the point is to have a billion and a
half people that speak
India
Hindi Hindi I don't know
um so whatever they speak in India I
have a billion and a half people
watching it in their own language it
would be made there it would be produced
there
um and it but it would be in the
Stargate Universe so then they might
watch our Stargate as well
um and they would hope we might watch
that Stargate but we probably won't but
they don't care because of billion and a
half Indians are going to watch it well
that's the thing you can get all the
English-speaking countries in the world
to watch it if you do it in English and
I I don't mean to be the American person
like do it out of English so we can
listen then watch and do yada yada yada
but like Kevin just said India is
English they I mean they they've been
nothing
people call Steve and things like that
here's an interesting number for you
there are more speakers of English in
China than there are uh natural speakers
you know first uh first language
speakers of English and the rest of the
world yeah I think
so they could do it all in English
but why not do a show actually in the
native language setting the native that
for that people that live there you
should include their native language but
if you ostracize your internet the show
doesn't stay International then it
becomes a very Niche show for a specific
region but what you could then do is
have actors that do crossover and they
would speak English in parts
okay so the Great Wall parts of it
spoken in Chinese both were spoken in
English and you could do that and then
like I said you have the the was it what
was it Shan Tzu was the Chinese
um
at 304 was it a chance or something like
that
so but they had their own shipped in the
China under their own 304.
um you could you could base a series on
that weather yeah okay they speak
Chinese most of the time but they would
speak English at times as well and they
would and you could even have stars from
the different shows crossing over I
don't know I I love that idea I think
that's a good idea the the only thing
that would would be difficult about that
is I think
uh in the same way where
you're gonna have
[Music]
I think I know where Harris is going
it's almost it's not necessarily it's a
good idea to have you know the central
you know localized stories of Stargate
here Stargate there but the issue is
it's a CPA issue with whoever's Bank
rolling the production because they want
to maximize the value of every stinking
dollar this kind of goes back to where
there's more control of the studio than
there are most governments and saying
what you produce and so you're it's just
it's a great idea and it'd be really
culturally valuable I think especially
artistically but there's a CPA with a
spreadsheet that's just going to tell
you [__] no well okay that and then the
the the the thought came back uh it it
would I feel like it would be not to
compare it to to this is just the only
like comparison that came to mind was
like I think people would think about it
or not necessarily think about it but
mentally it would process the same way
as
quote unquote woke stuff in in the sense
where the show would have to address
that so much that they're not actually
doing the show anymore they would have
to have like oh entire scenes for
interpreters where instead just go out
and do some cool [__] excuse my French
but just go out and do cool sci-fi stuff
and I think if we take the time to focus
on it's not focusing on gender or race
or ideology or something like that it
would be focusing on on language and
that's cool I love the exploration of
that my birth mom speaks nine and a half
languages like I love polyglots and and
being able to like go in a room and
communicate with people that you might
not be able to communicate with uh in
your language as well as their language
or or whatever that is and that could
definitely be a part of it but same
thing with the communication stones in
SGU I think it would be way too overused
and it would dilute the series where we
just want full sci-fi and John uh from
chat he had you know he says well how
are you going to deal with the whole one
Stargate thing well an idea I just had
would be like well what if you know
there's you know we do internationalize
it right and there's a whole show just
for the Indian SG team
you know let's say you know there's a
Russian team and a French team and a
Chinese team and it's just you know
Hammond is still you know dial the gate
well not now but you know somebody says
you know dial the gate and that part's
in English and then
um it's just an it is it is a series
still based in the SGC and in the world
it's just focused on that one specific
internet routine that's why I mentioned
like a Chinese 305 or in you know a the
Russian they wouldn't do production it's
no money in Russia
you know what I mean and then um but it
would all get dragged back to the main
show which would be
the one that's going to be filmed in
Canada probably
um I just think it's a nice I I just
like if you're going to do an
international TV show I think
Stargate is is ideally placed to it
you've got the central location but it's
an international worldwide project so
you've got an excuse to have
shows that are produced a show that's
produced in India show that's produced
in China and I'll show this and let's be
honest they would have loads of English
speaking in it and they would do a bit
of their native speaking to you know to
to cross both Bridges because they're
still going to want to watch it because
at least for now we are still the
largest market in the world between
America and Europe
we watch more TV than the rest of the
world put together Australia yeah we we
watch we watch TV like it's going on
Christmas
yeah well the rest of the world's
catching up but at the moment we're
still the biggest market so if they're
going to produce a TV show in India
they're still going to want us to watch
it
that's the way they'll be
I just think it's an interesting idea I
I don't have any sources to say that's
what they're going to do I did speak to
somebody to say look that's what
you know that well I've got a video
coming out in a few days I'll explain it
better then all right fine we'll wait
well I haven't quite got my thinking
straight yet so I'm still I'm still
trying to figure out how to
describe it you don't want to figure it
out for the next like 20 minutes on
stream and just just really cycle
through because I'm gonna now go and
have some TV uh right so hidden tape
will we Guys review the new Babylon 5
movie in a few weeks
I've ordered it
I don't know when it comes out I forget
it it premieres next week at San Diego
Comic-Con so I think it comes out just
after that so I should get it the week
after I will watch it and I will
probably get a copy and give it away if
people like it but I will be talking
about it
wrong
real quick did the secular monk just put
in a great comment how would you
establish what is Canon what wasn't if
what if the offshoot showed it something
outside Canon and it's not like that but
like okay so what if these different
offshoot shows start going to different
dimensions do they come back to the same
one do they what if they time travel
no whoever
I would have to do there would have to
be somebody in charge of all of them to
keep them all set
okay
okay so they would they would be it's
like the same show
but they would be produced across if
somebody yes I agree that somebody would
have to keep it all straight
or it's going to get confusing because
the idea would be to try to get
everybody to watch all of it I think
yeah that's what I would think
North Korean or South Korean I always
got those two mixed up why are we
watching South Korean TV and thing
um what do we say on the other side
there'll be a North Korean TV show be
very different yeah he's very very
different
but yeah um what's the second language
of sidetrack
gibberish and I think it's mainly our
first language
brain farts
nonsense and brain farts
yeah English is our second language
don't forget the Roundup I've got no
idea what you're talking about 100 what
what round we did the Roundup earlier
because we all talked about what we uh
watched earlier
yes we did we're not around it because
you usually do that at the end
yeah I don't know why they did the start
I don't either
ill dude have you watched anything else
no I tried to watch Foundation season
two and realized my Apple subscription
uh I gotta resubscribe
I'm gonna start it tomorrow because I
didn't think it'd come out yet so but
guys thank you so much as always you've
been marvelous
um about what I know oh I think you know
about stock yes I'll be doing that this
week
um uh doing a bit of a what do we
actually know about what's going on with
Stargate but unfortunately that video is
going to end up with
but thanks to the active strike we now
know nothing basically yeah so it's a
clean slate so I will talk about what we
think
we know up till now but then the problem
is we now know that Executives have got
time to stop and think about [__]
foreign
excellent show
um I've been meaning to watch it it's
you know it is a uh alternative history
of uh the uh race to land on the moon in
the Russians won
what's the setup for it and it's uh
produced by uh Ronald Moore of a
balustrial galactic Fame in Outlander
Fame yeah definitely must go watch
some of the best I'll tell you what some
of the best sci-fi today is on Apple
Plus
that quality over quantity over there
yeah oh and see
to watch that so bad
thing for today that's your thing for
this
yeah fixed get right with Apple
in that Feud
oh Foundation is excellent
if it is on Apple based on a series of
novels
yeah it's conceptual sci-fi I think it's
fair to say yes
um so it is gonna and it's oh you need
to take notes
yeah it's it's a from a series of novels
I think back in the 50s or 60s by Asimov
and I've always been a big fan of the
foundation trilogy
I just never knew how they were going to
film it you know it was
which I was just about to say they've
done an excellent job I have all nine of
those askimov novels upstairs uh in my
little library right here and uh the the
the I don't know if there's a way the
expanse could kind of follow suit in
some ways but I don't think so just
because you know their time ends up
being a big thing with their lighter
stuff or not really time it's more the
uh just the the story picks up further
down the line in time it's the same
thing with uh so what there's a 30-year
gap between uh book
uh yeah uh Silo is excellent
I thought you know it follows uh I think
personally I think it follows the um the
books quite religiously or respectfully
I should say
um it was still it's excellent even if
they do vary off your favorite Parts
it's still damn excellent handy I only
read the uh the first book but it's
still the the climax at the end of the
last episode is still shattering
the thing I like about Silo though is
because it is based on a series of books
and you see a Sci-Fi show like that and
I always have this like it's it's the
Lost moment in my head and when I see
something that's very conceptual and
something that's um quite big thinking
if you know what I mean I'm thinking are
these guys going to paint themselves
into a corner then I have to say God did
it
um but with Silo you know there's three
books there you know the guy had an idea
of where he was going and in the end
it's going to make sense at no point
will it be God did it so I like her I
have a confidence watching a show like
that there you go a foundation's the
same I know this is going somewhere
you know what I mean and it's like some
shows I think
the one that yeah
um you know Marie was talking about yeah
the second uh season two jumps about a
hundred and some years uh it is
confusing but the main characters remain
the same
which that's what I was trying to get at
was that's my I really love how they did
that the introducing the clianastic
dynasty of clones and because that's not
part of azimov's books at all but it
really helps us mentally bridge the gap
of time in a way this is a slick idea
yeah it was it was whoever came up with
that to write in there thank you it was
it was genius
I love that I love the morning
the thing in the Twilight I thought
that's just such a clever idea anyway
guys thank you so much in finishing the
Roundup finishing the Roundup the other
things that I'm reading still is uh Tree
Animal space janitor oh my God it's it's
really really entertaining Triana more
space janitor
it's just fun on a space station with
robots and murder gotta love it
okay and what's wrong with there's
nothing I mean throwing some nazisms
from sharks and I'm you've got me hooked
between four cornerstones
yeah they're the Cornerstone of
everything really isn't it Nazi sharks
robots and uh yeah
we used to have TV show a vehicle thank
you Sarah I appreciate that
no don't tell him that
we don't need
to do that we don't need any more of it
trust me um oh sentient Nancy sharks
with freaking laser beams on their head
that's what we want freaking laser beams
Indiana Jones movie yeah yeah freaking
laser beams our children in the basement
was two seconds behind me
um right guys thank you so much we are
going to call it an evening
um
we will see you next week I think we'll
be talking a little bit about
um the strike well maybe have a think
more about this Stargate where Stargate
is now and um I'll do a revive I'll do a
update video in the week then we'll have
a chat about it and and not just
Stargate though there's so many other
sci-fi projects that I think well maybe
I'll think about which ones do we think
might survive
the um strike if that's okay yeah so
what what do we think actually might
survive and what might not because
nothing is safe so we'll have to think
about it so guys we will see you next
week
um stay safe
have fun bye everybody
foreign